it's my pleasure to introduce our
speaker this evening Steve Forbes is
chairman and editor-in-chief of Forbes
media under his leadership Forbes media
has launched a number of publications
including Forbes Life
Forbes Europe and Forbes Asia he earned
his BA in history from Princeton
University in 1985 mr. Forbes was
appointed chairman of the board of
international broadcasting by President
Ronald Reagan in his position mr Forbes
oversaw the operations of Radio Free
Europe and Radio Liberty in both 1996
and 2000
mr Forbes campaigned for the Republican
nomination for the presidency he is the
author or co-author of numerous books
including freedom manifesto why free
markets are moral in big government
isn't flat tax revolution using a
postcard to abolish the IRS how
capitalism will save us why free people
and free markets are the best answer for
today's economy and most recently money
how the destruction of the dollar
threatens the global economy and what we
can do about it so please join me in
giving a warm welcome to mr. Steve
Forbes
well thank you thank you very much Nick
for those very kind words and thank all
of you for coming here being here on a
Sunday night it's always dangerous to
speak to a group after a dinner and on a
Sunday night very dangerous so I hope
the cold air and some caffeine at dinner
have perked you up and it is great fun
to be here at Hillsdale seeing the H
here reminds one that H can stand for
good things not just Harvard so
what is the pleasure see Larry Arne and
others who have nurtured and grown this
great institution thanks to your support
and one of the things that Hillsdale
preaches and practices is intellectual
diversity others are like often you know
oftentimes I can say because our kids
are out of their teen years but
teenagers often think they're very
rebellious but they all do the same
thing among their their peers and in
terms of universities in too many
academic institutions these days they
both preach diversity but you're allowed
to have diversity sort of like Henry
Ford when he learned that General Motors
was going to allow you to choose the
color of your own car Henry Ford
famously said you can have any color you
want
among Ford products which was one as
long as it is black and and and so in
terms of diversity it means just one
thing you march in line and if you're
out of line obviously you are dishonest
you're guilty of micro I love that word
micro aggression and every every other
sin in the book and they're now even
going after Exxon the Attorney General
in New York because they opposed the
idea of climate change global warming
therefore this may come under Rico a
racketeering thing they weren't telling
the truth therefore they must they must
be punished
so George Orwell Orwell was right you
can twist language in any which way and
say you're for the first amendment but
if you will commit a crime and not tell
the truth about climate change by golly
we can come after you
Stalin would have loved it but it is it
is a great honor to be here and I've
been asked tonight to talk about money
monetary policy and I do so with
trepidation and I'm glad you are a
polite audience because it's not the
most exciting subject in the world when
you say monetary policy Federal Reserve
of exchange rates quantitative easing
Ben Bernanke Janet yeah I mean the eyes
get heavy even though you know it's
important
and so this subject has not got the
excitement of fifty shades of gray it is
it is is not like watching naked in the
jungle
but so let me just give you a reward in
advance for what I'm about to do to you
and that is if you ever find yourself in
an airplane in coach middle seat on the
runway watching your life pass away you
want a little bit of elbow room with
your seat mates
start talking to them about monetary
policy yeah though they'll cut you a
wide berth so Wow well but while it is
not inherently sexy monetary policy
money is absolutely crucial you can get
things right on government spending you
can get it right on regulation you can
get it right on taxes but if you don't
get the money right you're gonna have a
troubled subpar economy and we see the
proof of it around the world today and
the monetary chaos around the world
critical reason why the world's in the
trouble that's that is in and as I'll
discuss critical reason why the US is in
the trouble that it is in and the reason
money is so crucial is simple how do we
progress how do we get ahead how do we
achieve a higher standard of living we
do it by trading with each other
buying and selling with each other
interacting with each other and money
simply makes it easier to do those
things you know otherwise we'd still be
living in caves subsistence level if we
couldn't engage in trade now to show why
there's more of me today than there was
ten years ago or five years ago I'll
give the example of safe baking a cake
think of all the little transactions you
do baking a cake how to get the egg the
milk the flour butter
spoons measuring spoons ovens
electricity the whole thing so without
trading we wouldn't get anywhere you
know in the old days before we had money
money makes trading much easier before
we had money we had barter which was
very inefficient you know we the what
economists call coincidence of wants so
if you didn't have the coincidence of
wants you couldn't make the transaction
you know let's let's say three thousand
years ago I sold an ad in Forbes how
would I get paid perhaps with a herd of
goats being a little facetious here but
let's say I wanted to buy iPads for our
writers so I go to the Apple store of
the herd of goats the Apple store owner
says he doesn't want goats he wants
sheep so I have to figure out how to
swap the goats for sheep perhaps have to
hire a sheep herder to make sure the
Wolves don't eat the Sheep now the sheep
herder wants to be paid with wine I've
got red wine he wants white wine
just-just-just just becomes very
inefficient you'll just imagine if we
had barter today imagine trying to
deposit a pig into an ATM or withdrawing
a cow or chicken just just doesn't work
very well so money money was invented in
the marketplace not by government
although government soon got involved as
it doesn't really do with wealth or
wealth creation but it was invented in
the marketplace people trying to figure
out ways to make it easier to do
business with one another buy and sell
with one another and the transactions
are critical I mean Adam Smith you all
know what Adam Smith told us about
transactions each gets something from
the trade each gets something from the
trade contrary to what a lot of the left
believes transactions are way we get
ahead it's not greed we each get
something for it some things are more
fun to buy than others buying a handbag
is fun buying a sports car is fun much
more fun than paying the electricity
bill or paying the rent if you rent a
place although it's amazing the people
who complain about electricity bills and
the like don't hesitate to go out and
spend two or three hundred dollars on a
pair of
blue jeans that look like they came from
a dumpster go figure that's that's human
nature but money money makes
transactions infinitely easier you
determine what you get in the
transaction I say you will you pay me
money for a subscription I determine
what I get in return
for that trade money money this has no
intrinsic value that's what economists
have too many in the Federal Reserve and
elsewhere don't understand money in and
of itself has known trinsic value it's
often just a few ellipses on a computer
pieces of paper it's not wealth money
measures wealth money measures value
money measures value the weigh scales
measure weight rulers measure length
clocks measure time money's like a claim
check you know you go to a restaurant
you deposit your coat you get a claim
check money is simply a claim on
products and services and it's based on
trust but unfortunately our authorities
believe today you might call it the coat
check theory of economics you know if
you understand the money is a claim on
products and services you'll see how
silly it is to think if you do more
money you somehow create more products
and services no money represents
products and services so let's say a
restaurant let's say a Rus say Ben
Bernanke was running a restaurant and he
figures out that if he creates more coat
checks
that'll stimulate the creation of more
coats which will mean more customers in
the restaurant that's about the level of
thinking the Federal Reserve today and
so
coach Eck theory of economics it's a or
you know not to belabor the thing but
you know after World War Two in the
Pacific some Island Islanders remember
you may have read about the cargo cult
and the the the locals during the war
saw when we built these runways that
people would wave sticks in the air and
out would come a plane out of the sky
and discourage all this stuff and they
figured out after the war if they built
a tower and went up the tower and wave
sticks that somehow these great birds
from the sky would come and disgorge
stuff that innit that also represents
the federal reserve waive the sticks and
this stuff will come but you know as you
know as you know critical to markets
critical of functioning market is fixed
weights and measures you buy a pound of
cheese you assume it's sixteen ounces it
doesn't vary in weight each day the
dealer's honest doesn't float from
thirteen ounces one day to eighteen the
next ruler twelve inches in a foot that
doesn't float that doesn't change each
day you buy a gallon of gasoline you
assume it's the same volume of liquid
today as it was yesterday and be the
same thing tomorrow and so if you
understand that thing you can understand
that money works best when it has a
fixed value now just to hammer home the
point imagine what your life would be
like if the Federal Reserve was put in
charge of clocks and watches and they
decide to float the hour decide to float
clocks they have 60 minutes an hour one
day 42 minutes an hour the next 88
minutes the day after and be chaotic be
chaotic
now imagine baking a cake that cake I
talked about this says bake the batter
for 35 minutes you'd have to figure out
is that nominal minutes
inflation-adjusted minutes is it is it a
Michigan minute a mexican minute you'd
have you know futures and minutes so the
the perils the perils of unstable money
when it doesn't have that
value or multitudinous first of all you
all know prices disseminate critical
information prices tell us what what
what something is valued at whether it's
a short supplier and surplus prices give
us information well when you have
unstable money that's like a virus in
the computer it corrupts the information
one example go back to the 1970s none of
you remember the 1970s yeah that's
called pandering I tried it in politics
didn't work which is why I'm here
tonight
catching free meals off a Larry Arne but
but back back back in the 1970s we went
off the rails on money we had a huge
inflation oil went from around $3 a
barrel almost $40 a barrel the price was
going up copper one up commodities went
up and everyone figured well the prices
going up it must mean we're running out
of the stuff there's not enough of it
out there but it turns out that high
price seemingly was not so much scarcity
as it was the weak dollar so in the
early 1980s Ronald Reagan and Paul
Volcker then then head of the Fed kill
the terrible inflation what happens to
oil comes crashing down almost $40 about
at $10 a barrel finally stabilizes at 20
to 25 Texas went through a virtual
depression in the mid 1980s you saw the
same thing in agriculture commodity
prices were going up land prices were
seemingly going up so hail plant from
fence post to fence post borrow lever
because by golly this thing this thing
was going on and on so he had a
depression in the in agriculture Iowa
was hit hard housing also had a bit of a
bubble but because Fannie and Freddie
weren't as big then we didn't have the
Community Reinvestment Act that that
that disaster would come later but in
the early 2000s we went off the rails
again and by the way talking about oil
those of you in the business well know
from the mid 80s to the early part of
the last decade the average price of oil
was a little over $21 a barrel then we
went off the rails again
the Federal Reserve and the Treasury
Department decided to weaken the dollar
help pull us out of they thought the
2000-2001 recession but they kept on
because they thought that would help
exports
you know cheat on the prices that'll
help but give you some quick prosperity
and so look what happened oil went up
from the 20s $100 a barrel a couple of
years ago the Fed started inadvertently
tightening again I'll discuss that in a
minute they didn't know what they were
doing nothing new dollar strengthens
commodities crash another period of
chaos so what happens when you have
unstable money not only do prices not
give you reliable information anymore
you get less investment you know better
than anyone investing is risky but if
you don't know what you're gonna see you
invest in something that's unknown or
that is not yet seen building a new
factory new product creating a new
service maybe a year five years in year
the drug business ten years before you
get get the return on the investment and
so if you don't know what you're that's
risky enough if you don't know what
you're gonna get paid back in is it
going to be a $0.10 on the dollar fifty
cents on the dollar dollar ten on the
dollar you don't know and so it's no
surprise with this instability of the
dollar that what you might call
productive investment productive
risk-taking it's going into the tank and
one of the things that happens as I
mentioned money goes into hard assets
the things that already exist so right
now the dollar is strong temporarily so
we're on a roller coaster it's like a
watch a watch that's either too slow or
too fast
neither one does you any good and that's
the kind of situation we have now we
don't have an accurate timepiece when
the watch is going all over the place
you have also the same thing with money
so today's currencies absolutely
unstable dollars like a yo-yo and so we
have the spectacle today currency
trading when the dollar was fixed in
value didn't need much currency trading
today the amount of volume of currency
trading nominal value is over five
trillion dollars a day
more than stocks and bonds and so we had
a period of a week dollar from 2001 to
2013 now we have a temporally strong
dollar week dollars why we got the
commodities boom strong dollars why now
we're getting the opposite so these
things they get these false bubbles I
mean look what happened to housing goose
by Fannie and Freddie and Community
Reinvestment Act and quotas and subprime
mortgages and the like well we never
would have had that bubble on certainly
not on the scale we did if the dollar
hadn't been weakened and money was
seeking hard assets but you know again
talking about corrupting the price
prices of houses go up people figure
well they're not enough of them price
keeps going up they invented a new
mortgage the new mortgage was why have
an income you know just keep keeps going
up you know what what's the point
and so then you get the inevitable you
get the inevitable day after the morning
after and so you get less real lending
productive lending in the credit markets
today this is compounded by severe
regulations on banks you're in the
banking business you know regulators
sometimes go over them almost every loan
you make and so then they wonder why
with that kind of hyper regulation why
we don't get the kind of lending to
small and new businesses that are the
job creators so in terms of in terms of
what's taking place today in terms of
what's taking place today the Federal
Reserve you member of Laurel & Hardy
when Hardy would turn to Laurel and say
you this is a fine mess you've made
Federal Reserve is doing the same thing
you know after after after the 2008-2009
Tubac oh we're just trying to come off
of it now what do they do
maybe they buy up all long-term bonds
they're trying to suppress interest
rates across the board so there has now
a bloated portfolio but you know what
they did with that by suppressing prices
the distortion was one critical reason
why we have this semi recession today
they suppress prices you know price
controls don't work
take rent controls it's great if you
have an apartment that already exists
you don't mind like a maintenance but
you know $10 a rent on Park Avenue and
that sounds pretty good but no one's
gonna build an apartment a new one when
you have below market or don't know what
you're gonna get in terms of being able
to charge for a price same thing is in
terms of lending they suppress interest
rates across the board not just
short-term rates but long-term rates
first time outside of a major war they
tried that trick and so what happens is
if you don't know what you're gonna get
on a loan especially when regulators are
looking over your shoulder less lending
lending takes place and so what you have
what the Federal Reserve did with zero
interest rates and quantitative easing
was they've distorted the credit markets
they distorted in this way lending to
government new credit to the government
new credit to the government in the last
five years overall government in this
country has gone up 37 percent the
increase in credit to large companies
has gone up to going up 32 percent
lending to small businesses and
households up 6 percent pitiful pitiful
figure for a supposed recovery and so in
terms of sounds near-zero were in to
zero interest rates sounds great but
remind you the saying the old Soviet
Union where they said the health care
was free the health care is free but you
can't get any and that's and that's and
that's what's unfolded today so
perversely the more the federal reserve
suppresses interest rates the longer it
does it longer you're not going to have
a healthy functioning credit market so
like what the Fed does is like saying
let's deal with obesity by changing
scales you know if you increase the
number of ounces in a pound from 16 to
32 lose half your weight that's that
sounds pretty good but in terms but in
term terms of the real world it does not
work does not work
and so this instability is very hurtful
and has political consequences you don't
get growth when you don't get growth and
income stagnate their political
repercussions we see that in Europe we
see that in other parts of the world
we're seeing it here scapegoating
increases whether it's immigrants the
rich the bankers or the idlers living
off the government or even police people
looking for a reason what what is going
on and it's not just about GDP meeting
and comes in the like unstable money
also undermines what you might call
social trust money is based on trust as
I said earlier pieces of paper blips on
a computer you assume that claim works
but if it starts to shift in value and
you don't understand why then it
corrodes trust with other things money
is what holds the society together
interacting with each other and so what
happens john maynard keynes occasionally
he got something right back in 1919 he
said Keynes with said Lenin was
certainly right there is no sutler no
sure means of overturning the existing
basis of society than to debauch the
currency the process engages all the
hidden forces of economic law on the
side of destruction and does so in a
manner which not one man in a million is
able to diagnose ponder that people
suddenly see values values getting
distorted things the values don't work
anymore and so the irony is came just
talking about a hyperinflation the kind
that hit rush of the kind would hit
Germany would set the stage for Hitler
but he didn't realize because he didn't
realize that you can have a slow-motion
debasement of the currency or a
slow-motion undermining of faith in the
currency and still get the same result
even though it takes
goes over a period of time and so think
of it you know John Locke worried about
warned about when you have unstable
money what it does between creditor and
lender both end up not getting what they
contracted for you see with the subprime
mortgage boom and then bust or mortgages
lenders banks ended up taking a hit
borrowers ended up taking a hit research
shows but when you have weak money crime
goes up research shows that in countries
with stable money you have more trust
with people you have long-term higher
growing rates of growth when countries
or currencies are chronically unstable
not to be politically offensive but I'm
not running for anything you take a
country like Brazil which is always
debasing its currency they have periods
of stability but then they go back into
their bad habits and so what I won't so
it's no no real mystery as to why their
police are not trusted why they have a
lot of why the police are always looked
at as engaging in quiet murders on the
side no social trust and you hear it as
I mentioned you see it here at home weak
money unstable money unstable money and
flames perceptions of unfairness that's
why there's all this talk of cronyism
people getting ahead not through doing
honest business for having a product or
service that people like but through who
you know who gives you the favors that's
why people feel that maybe the next
generation isn't going to do as well as
this generation so you have more social
divisions politicians see an opening the
1% versus the 99%
47% versus everyone else young versus
all public sector versus the private
sector unstable money mark mocks values
mocks honest effort the clink between
honest effort and reward it mocks
prudence remember a thing called
interest to refer to earlier once upon a
time if you made a deposit save money
Lent money you've got something in
return for it so prudence is mocked it
feels extremes so what do we do about it
short-term the Fed should just realize
that it can't manage an economy the
Soviet Union shows that mandarins cannot
manage economies the Fed can't do it
either
Mason Lee because monetary policy so
boring so intimidating it doesn't get
much examination politically that it
should and so the Fed has become an
immensely powerful institution
allocating credit distorting markets I
mentioned earlier about the growth of
credit to big companies versus small
businesses take when you have cheap
money those who can't get it can't get
it but those who can get it gorge on it
take Apple I love Apple Apple Computer
but Apple today now has over two hundred
billion dollars of cash yet in the
recent years
Apple has borrowed 40 billion dollars in
bonds issued 40 billion dollars of bonds
why when you have so much cash would you
borrow money like that the answer is
because it could it could do it for tax
purposes it could do it financial
engineering not so long ago issued a
bunch of 10-year bonds where they yield
thanks to the Fed was less than the
yield on Apple's dividend so why
wouldn't you borrow the money by in the
stock you look at the recent increase in
profits a lot of us what is financial
engineering great for the stockholders I
love it but not a very efficient and
productive use of capital but that's
what happens so what should the Fed do
short term start start letting this
bloated quantitative easing created
portfolio run down when a bond becomes
due don't reinvest it but the cash go
back into the economy into the banking
system that would be huge another thing
they should do is let interest rates
start to
their natural level the amazing thing is
credit would not credit would be more
plentiful and credit would flow in a
more efficient productive manner than it
is today it could go to smaller and new
businesses again cease this hyper
regulation where bureaucrats substitute
their judgment for those of bankers but
banker messes up bankers mess up let
them suffer the consequences for it but
don't have a bureaucrat thinking they
can do better for those of you who want
to get in this or want to impress people
a cocktail party talk about the evils of
Basel three tell them first is not
cooking Basel basel refers to banking
regulators around the world they come
together in Basel Switzerland to try to
come up with international regulations
because after all we live in a global
economy it sounds benign
one of the silly things they started to
do years ago was try to assign risk try
to assign a level of risk to different
levels of assets for example they
determined that the most riskless asset
you could have as a bank government
bonds so therefore you didn't need
hardly any reserves for government bonds
the next next less risky thing was
mortgages heard that word before
and the riskiest thing they determined
was loans to businesses so for example
before Greece's problems became public
the regulator's under Basel determined
that a loan to the Greek government was
less risky than a loan to IBM or Apple
that's Basel crazy so stop the hyper
regulation throw Basel out and put it
back in the kitchen or send it to
Switzerland but don't don't have it be
regulating and then there are few other
more technical things that can be done
but ultimately and this will sound very
strange so I'm counting on your
politeness ultimately we have
to go to where we were for 180 years it
wasn't perfect but link the dollar to
gold he said oh my god this guy is he of
survivalist you know cuz he he's you up
in the hills with his canned goods you
know waiting waiting for the end barbed
wire around the house no no there's so
much myth about gold I'm not gonna get
in tonight but think of gold as you
would a yardstick the yardstick of value
or a scale that measures wait why would
you link a currency to gold because it
works
it's like Polaris Gold keeps for a
variety of reasons which I'll touch on
gold keeps its value better than any
other thing on earth better than silver
but in copper better than bottles of
water oil whatever and there were there
were several Froude reasons for it one
is it's rare but not too rare you can't
destroy it you know you can beat it
smash it heat it freeze it but you can't
destroy it
every ounce that's been mined still
exists experts estimate we've mined
about 6 billion ounces we accounted for
about five and a half billion so it's
been pointed out if you have a gold ring
there may be particles and then they go
back to Egyptian favorite times you get
no supply shocks after all you don't
consume gold
it's very most of its not used and so
it's not like wheat where you get a
drought that'll affect the that'll
affect the price it's not consumed right
away it's strong but it's malleable
it's compact something like having the
whole oil around very compact you know
easy to store you don't have to worry
about termites or mice eating the gold
very easy to store so it has that so it
keeps its intrinsic value when you see
the price of gold fluctuate that's not
the intrinsic value of gold fluctuating
as much as is market perceptions about
the value of the currency now and fears
or hopes for the few
so gold fixed fluctuation there in the
dollar price the markets perceptions
about the dollar so it's like a
yardstick it doesn't restrict money
supply it just makes sure like your
cruise control on a car you're going at
a certain speed so throw out one other
statistic from 1775 to 1900 when we went
from a small East Coast barely
agricultural nation mostly subsistence
farming to 1900 when our population had
grown almost 25 fold greatest industrial
nation in the world dollar was fixed a
gold except during the Civil War in the
aftermath but it was everyone understood
there was be linked to gold during that
period of time the amount of gold mined
in the world went up about three and a
half fold the money supply in the US
during that period went up a hundred and
sixty fold so again just as a ruler
twelve inches in a foot doesn't restrict
the size of a building you may wish to
construct so to having a currency with a
fixed value doesn't restrict the size of
the economy if you have the right
policies the right environment the right
culture you'll have a big money supply
that's why the British money supply was
so big in than in the 1800s people just
in Britain didn't want it they wanted it
but so did everyone else around the
world because it was seen as the perfect
currency so portion utley per capita
pounds per capita in Britain were high
monetarist looking at that might say oh
my god there's too much money creation
no was demand people wanted it use it
just as they used to use the dollar so
how would a thing how would a gold
standard work very simple just just
strip away all the gobbledygook let's
say we fix it eleven hundred dollars an
ounce
all that means is if it goes above
eleven hundred you tighten up that goes
below eleven hundred you ease up that's
simple that's simple
and so in terms of what the Fed has done
today it's created an artificial
shortage of dollars because the hyper
regulation and what it's done people not
knowing what the real price of money is
so it's hurting the economy before that
it created weaken the dollar with the
connivance of our Treasury Department
we saw the chaos that came out of that
so you want to fix value just as you
want a fixed number of minutes in an
hour it's basic but they don't yet get
it fortunately fortunately things are
beginning to change
you saw one little in the intellectually
these things are very slow but people
are starting to look a gold standard and
I say a gold standard because they're
numerous variations of it there's not
one gold standard just as like there's
not one kind of democracy our rules are
different from Canada's Canada's
electoral rules are different from
Britain's Britain's different from
Germany France each has their own
permutate differences but essence on the
gold standard is it's fixed to a fixed
value and you can have the old classical
gold standard but you don't even run a
modern one you don't even know you need
to own an ounce of gold just look at the
price each day high school students
could run the system Hillsdale graduates
would be dominating the system but it
would bring an end who would bring an
end to the chaos we see in the world
today you got to get the money right and
the good news is that intellectual
ferment is just beginning there's a bill
before Congress from the man who's going
to be heading up the new Ways and Means
Committee now that Paul Ryan is going to
become speaker phone named Kevin Brady
congressman from Texas he wants a
commission of people sanctioned by
Congress to examine where we go in terms
of monetary policy that's the way you
get the debate and discussion going
little over a year ago Paul Volcker made
the observation that since we blew up
the Bretton Woods monetary system which
was gold based after World War two and
by the way in the 50s and 60s under that
system
the US growth rates are about 50% higher
than we've had since we went off a gold
standard but Volker said that since we
blew up the Bretton Woods system we've
had more chaos around the world more
currency crisis and research has shown
that Bank of England did some research a
couple of years ago so he didn't endorse
a gold standard but he recognized as
others are beginning to recognize that
what we're doing is not working and so
the way get changed the beginning as the
question it's not working where do we go
from here what do we do next
another little harbinger was on that
debate CNBC debate there's a good
question that was asked it happened that
night when when Rick Santelli got to hat
asked his little questioned yesterda
Cruz and then of Rand Paul he said what
about the Federal Reserve what do you
think should be done about it what are
they doing right what are they doing
wrong and Cruz and his answer senator
Cruz in his answer talked about auditing
the Fed and all that stuff feds got to
stop manipulating markets then he said
ideally he said the dollar should be
linked to Gold and known of course
followed up on it but that's the
beginning Cruz is interested in it I've
talked to him after that debate so it's
beginning to happen not overnight but
that's how things begin to happen they
get a discussion and you combine that
with what's happening on taxes look
what's happening on taxes on the
Republican side almost every candidate
has put out a plan for Tax
Simplification now only three of them
four of them have a flat tax that's four
more than there was four years ago eight
years ago 12 years ago I ran 16 years
ago so there's one flat tax err this
time there four of them now the their
variations and how they're doing it dr.
ben Carson former senator Santorum Rand
Paul has won Ted Cruz has won
but they're out there discussing it the
others have their simplification they
have more than one rate but with one
exception the highest rate is 25 8%
somehow some of them have as low as 25
or 23 percent now the one exception
we've got to educate him is senator
Rubio he has his high rate as he has to
rates 15 percent and 35 percent that's
almost like 39.6 and his 35% rate hits
incomes far lower than they do in the
current tax code he makes up for it he
says with having a big kitty credit the
French tried that it doesn't work in
terms if you want to goose up families
that's that's a whole nother matter but
other than that they're all in the 20s
now you say so they're so big things are
gonna happen already among Democrats and
Republicans there's now a consensus and
on the corporate side we got to change
things the only outliers the White House
which to them tax reform means higher
taxes their version of a flat tax is 100
percent what did you make send it in you
know two to two line flat tax but among
most Democrats there's a realization I
think after this election since so many
Republicans are in favor of
simplification you're gonna get a
mandate for tax reform on the personal
and corporate side and that'll be huge
because if we do it other nations will
do it on Reagan put on those sweeping
tax cuts in the early 80s within a few
years 50 nations around the world
followed suit if we get it right the
rest of the world has a chance to get it
right we have to lead the way other
countries can do it but this country
they will follow if they see that it is
working so it is critical now you say
well aren't two or three rates there in
the 20s
teens high rate of 25 percent that's
pretty good right sure it is let's go
for the pure because this is what
happened some of you may remember back
in 1986 in 1986 there was tax reform
they got rid of tax shelters
had two tax rates 15% 28% remember under
Reagan when he took office the highest
rate was 70 they got it down to 28 but
they left two rates in there ladies and
gentlemen
putting two tax rates together is like
putting two rabbits together they
multiply within a few within a few years
of 86 that went up to three then four
now it's seven when you include
clawbacks it's almost infinite number of
marginal tax rates that are out there in
this complicated code but the good news
is politico's are starting to move in
the right direction the good news is on
money it's just beginning people
realizing and even though it's will take
a few years before we get to what we did
for 180 years modernize it there are a
lot of things we can do to make sure the
Fed undoes the damage and the other big
thing on health care I'm not going to
get in tonight we just don't have the
time the big thing on health care that
is starting to take place
in this crazy environment just got to
get through the next couple of years
this for the first time we're getting
more consumer consumerism in health care
we're gonna get a real free market in
health care just ask yourself step back
for a moment ask yourself why do we have
a health care crisis and everyone says
well because people like me are getting
older we want more of it so prices keep
going up demand for health care seen as
a disaster but why demand for anything
else is considered a great opportunity
people want more cars and trucks
manufacturers in Detroit and elsewhere
glad to help you out people want more
apps a lot of writers glad to help you
out but yet in health care it's seen as
a disaster that people want more of it
it's because we we have this disconnect
between providers and consumers and the
proof of it is finally hit me a few
years ago if you go to a clinic or
hospital and you ask in advance what the
treatment costs very strange look means
one of two things either you're
uninsured or you're crazy
why would you want to know the price
what's it to you
he imagined going out and buying a nice
meal saying I don't care what it costs
that Medicare Blue Shield or at enough
worry about it system goes crazy that's
gonna change you see little signs of it
then we'll close little signs of it flu
shots talking about delivery of health
care once upon a time you wanted a flu
shot
make an appointment go to the doc clinic
or hospital big deal now you get it
anywhere go to the drugstore go to the
airport go to the gas station say fill
er up give me a flu shot through the
windshield BBB on your way you start to
see more and more walk-in clinics CVS
Walgreens and others you go in nurse
practitioner research shows 80% of our
maladies can be treated by technicians
or nurse practitioners and the like 20%
we need the full-fledged doc so it's
beginning to change and big things are
coming in terms of cures immunotherapies
and cancer and the like big positive
things coming but they won't come if we
don't have real free markets and finally
where patients and doctors can make
decisions and not third-party
bureaucrats that has got to happen and
it will happen so the key thing on
healthcare just don't get sick for the
next three years till we sort this do we
sort this thing out but the amazing
thing is by trying to socialized
healthcare Obama is seven forces doing a
lot of destruction in its wake but
certain forces that's going to get
turned healthcare from a seemingly
hopeless liability into the most dynamic
growth industry ever why because
healthcare is the most personal thing
out there more than taxes or anything
else healthcare hits us it's our friends
families in a way that nothing else does
so bottom line on the money and I
focused on tonight because I was asked
by Larry but it is one area that hasn't
received the attention that health care
is getting that taxes are getting but it
needs to be done because we got to get
that right fix weights and measures it
works everywhere and
including money thank you
so you know we have some helpers here
students with microphones raise your
hand and they will bring the microphone
to you the handheld's to you and we'll
be on our way
following the conclusion of this session
mr Forbes has agreed to sign copies of
his book money how the destruction of
the dollar threatens and what we can do
about it on the other side of this
curtain as mr. Forbes said we had now
have time for a few questions Steve
thank you very much for your global
economy and what we can do about it on
the other side of this curtain as mr.
Forbes said we had now have time for a
few questions
Steve lecture tonight one quick question
I've been looking at this 50 years in my
lifetime it seems to me it comes down to
people and virtual people people with
virtue and money is a virtuous thing if
it's handled correctly in a very evil
thing if it's not done correctly and as
US private individuals out here looking
at this mess what can we do to help
progress this process to get the virtual
people first by your being here and
showing a keen interest in what what is
happening and where we've gone wrong
that that's that's a critical step the
others to share it I mean in Primus I
mean share start sharing this there are
a lot of good think tanks out there that
do a good research on this and in terms
of areas where you may not have an
expertise I mean there's no way one
human being can be an expert on
everything unless you're in politics and
we see where that leads but but but the
but the key thing is then either learn
about it or ask your representatives we
got to mess at the Fed what are you
doing about it for example next time
Janet Yellen goes before Congress and
she's done this before
or joy says we want 2% inflation which
when you think about is kind of nuts why
why do you want unstable money but they
believe that inflation causes prosperity
so she wants two percent inflation why
don't have a representative ask her that
means for a typical family making
$50,000 a year their prices would go up
a thousand dollars two percent of fifty
thousand why do one thousand dollars of
higher expenses stimulate the economy
for a middle-class family who gave you
the authority to put that tax increase
in and take take it from there and
believe me if you representatives start
to believe there's some interest in this
they will start to learn about it just
for thing called sheer survival so yeah
take it from here so I liked your talk
but I really didn't understand the joke
at the beginning about Harvard
University what's you know you know my
best friends are at Harvard I know so so
so are some of mine shows great
tolerance that and you you you you know
the old joke you can always tell a
Harvard man because he will tell you
it's true even today now the co-ed a lot
of the graduates you talk with in ten
minutes it'll slip out that they went to
Harvard that's just I don't know what
what that is but anyway go ahead I want
to understand better your view on
monetary policy since the end of the
financial crisis say since 2009 mm if
you look at the monetary part there's
been this explosion of the Fed's balance
sheet and various monetary aggregates
and it looked very unstable but if you
look at inflation it's actually been
extremely low and it's been quite stable
particularly compared with other periods
so if you look at the monetary side you
say with monetary instability if you
look at inflation side you'd say it was
almost price stability so I wonder how
you look at that contrast well first of
all in terms of put aside how you
measure the cost of living put put that
question aside there's a whole debate on
how you should compute the CPI where
they can really compute an accurate one
put that aside but in terms of since
2009 what the Fed has done is by they've
exploded their balance sheet which the
70 should have would have told us since
that proportionally they've done twice
as much but they call creation of
monetary reserves bank reserves the
monetary thing called m0 twice the rate
they did in the 70 so why isn't
everything going up 20 percent a year
the reason is with those with those
reserves with the money that they can
affect created what they did was first
they bought long-term bonds sold their
short-term bought long-term bonds to
suppress interest rates but they also
put in a regular and they also gave you
interest on those reserves and they also
put in a regular harsh regulatory regime
after dodd-frank so in effect the money
was not lent out into the economy the
banks found it far easier just to let it
sit at the
that earn you 25 basis points which was
higher than you'd get on you short-term
Treasuries and since you didn't know
what the real price of money was and you
looked at the mortgage market where yes
those teaser rates were great but when
the way and when they went up what it
looked like a solvent borrower suddenly
became a very insolvent borrower are you
going to risk regulatory ire lending to
an entity where you don't know where the
real price of what you're lending is
you're gonna the regulator's gonna want
this paper at six ways to Sunday it's
just much easier to let it sit at the
Fed so what the Fed is done in effect is
expropriated almost three trillion
dollars of cash you look at the bank
balance sheets almost seventeen eighteen
percent of their assets and now parked
at the Federal Reserve so the money
didn't go in the economy it's like
filling up the reservoir and then
blocking the pipes so never made its way
into the economy and what it did do is
that by gumming up the credit markets so
you weren't gonna take a risk it went to
the apples it went to the federal
government and more than it did to like
in a normal credit market where all
sorts of borrowers would have access
you'd pay a price but you get the credit
there's a little piece some of you've
heard of Steve Moore the economist he
wrote a piece a couple of few weeks ago
he was denied a mortgage because he was
not getting at government guaranteed
mortgage even though he had a nice
income his bride-to-be had a nice income
they'd put down twenty five thirty
percent down payment no bank some of the
big banks turned them down for a
mortgage
why because several years ago he was
late on a couple of credit card payments
and that's a red flag to the regulators
if the mortgage is not government
guaranteed so here's a guy perfectly
good income pays his bills for the good
FICO score twenty five percent down for
Wells Fargo and others would not lend
and make the mortgage so you're right
the monetary base exploded but they did
something different and a lot of people
have missed
and I'd ask the fundamental question why
when he had this huge explosion in the
monetary base why didn't you get what
happened in the 70s because what
happened this time through regulation
through paying on reserves and other
things the money never was lent out into
the economy you didn't have the leverage
you know when you go to school they say
$1.00 of high powered money creates 8 to
10 dollars of loans you know they walk
you through the thing didn't happen this
time and that's the big difference and
so that's why we've had this subpar
recovery is the credit markets didn't
work plus you add on to that this to the
silliness being polite of Obamacare and
regulatory binging where the government
is involved and gets more involved in
everything you've got this Consumer
Protection Agency inside the Fed raging
war jihad against auto dealers and by
the way you thought NSA was not looking
at your specific phone calls but looking
for patterns and the hooha that caused
this new consumer protection agency is
sconce inside the Fed that gets all of
its money from the Fed not through
congressional appropriation they're
looking they're looking at patterns on
your credit cards see if something's
going wrong it's a fishing expedition
there's a piece in the journal under a
couple few months ago so it's a
different environment and part of our
problem is it's human nature we always
fight the last war it's not just
generals and admirals until we do it all
the time business you do it all the time
we say we've experienced this thing so
we figured it's going to repeat itself
but what happened with the Fed this time
had a very different end result than
what happened in the 70s and the other
thing is in the early part of the decade
he saw some increase in the Consumer
Price Index but this was mainly went
into assets commodities and houses a
little bit on land I remember speaking
in Nebraska a couple of years ago
and warning them his land prices were
moving up I said you know we went
through this in the 70s they said oh yes
this time we're well aware of it
we're not leveraging these were farmers
not leveraging the way we did in the 70s
and they said the ones who are really
binging on it are not farmers but
investors outside investors funds and
the like so we'll see how that plays out
but it was very different the thing to
keep in mind is very different what
they've done is for the moment killed
monitor the traditional way we thought
credit was created in the economy high
powered money leveraged 8 to 10 to 1 not
not working today for variety of reasons
that's the key thing we have time for
one more question
when Carter became president inflation
shot up to 18 percent I thought we had
joined the ranks of the banana republics
then the reagan became president and i
thought finally we have turned the
corner we are no longer on the road to
serfdom now 20-30 years later we are
still firmly on the road to serfdom so
even if he kept a reagan again will it
make any difference because afterwards
we will still go back to walking down
the road to serve them a question about
how after reagan could we be in the mess
that were in today and part of the
answer is we did not have then the what
you might call the base of intellectual
understanding and ideas and advocates
that we had that that today though we
have today that we did not have 35 years
ago and in terms even among Republicans
35 years ago there's sort of the feeling
that government should play a real big
role and yeah we shouldn't have
inflation we should cut tax rates but
they didn't take it to the next to the
next step and I think now morally people
are beginning to realize that if you
believe in free markets you just can't
say they work you also have to make the
moral case for free markets
and that's the that's still a big task
in front of us that's why I wrote that a
couple of books on it others are doing
it
numerous have done it for a number of
years but in essence you succeed in free
markets by meeting the needs and wants
of other people you can't even if you
lust for money you don't get it unless
you provide something that somebody else
wants now sometimes as Steve Jobs said
when he was asked you see if job is
asked once do you do marketing surveys
and he famously replied no because
people don't know what they want until
we show them that's all part of
entrepreneurship you've tried something
new you don't know if it's gonna work
people suddenly they may discover they
couldn't live without it but meeting the
needs and wants of other people and just
keep in mind philanthropy and commerce
are often portrayed as polar opposites
you succeed in commerce you make up for
your sins by giving it away to
philanthropy they're not polar opposites
they're two sides of the same coin
meeting the needs and wants of other
people different ways to do it but same
objective which is why the u.s. the most
commercial nation ever invented it's
also the most philanthropic nation in
the world two sides of the same coin we
have to make that moral case and there's
a lot more understanding about economics
a lot more understanding about free
markets today than there was 35 years
ago 60 years ago 80 years ago now we
know more and more that when you get
these big economic crises it's not a
sudden failure free marker outbreak of
greed
it is massive government policy error
now I just want to say it doesn't excuse
wrongdoing in free markets or wrongdoing
by bankers or anybody else but human
nature hasn't changed in thousands of
years people's ability to do bad things
preceded Adam Smith believe me just look
at the Bible you can see this is some
predate of Adam Smith so it's a very
good question but now I think we are
setting the foundation where
we get a good president good but what we
want is understanding as hills dales
tried to do where even if you get them
total mediocrity the accepted wisdom is
Constitution free markets having a moral
basis of a free society those things
should and when that happens you don't
have to depend on a Reagan when you have
that kind of consensus so we got to get
the consensus right and not be dependent
on particular outstanding individuals
thank you very much